hoy en este primer día de cumbre
iberoamericana número 28 hay dos grandes
acontecimientos en la agenda por un lado
estaría la ceremonia inaugural que
tendrá lugar más tarde en el centro de
Santo Domingo en el centro de la ciudad
pero ya en unos minutos va a empezar
aquí en el centro de convenciones del
Ministerio de exteriores aquí en el
mismo Malecón donde nos encontramos la
reunión de cancilleres de ministros de
exteriores Y hay como bien lo decías
unos temas muy marcados en la agenda y
unas cuestiones oficiales no que figuran
digamos en la lista de temas a tratar en
esta en esta Cumbre como es la seguridad
alimentaria la el combate la lucha
contra el cambio climático también está
digamos la petición de una nueva
arquitectura financiera y esto según nos
decían es una de las cuestiones que
menos consenso encuentra al menos así
fue ayer durante la reunión de
coordinación de las distintas
delegaciones que se alargó muchísimo por
digamos A falta de consenso entre otros
temas en este no que quiere que los
países de América Latina y el Caribe
puedan acceder más fácilmente a créditos
y a préstamos no internacionales pero
como bien lo decías es bastante poco
probable que los líderes de América
Latina se encuentren Y no discutan de
temas que vertebran tanto en la
actualidad de la región como es la
migración como es la necesidad de
cooperar regionalmente para combatir el
crimen internacional o también digamos
la relación con la Unión Europea y es
que recordemos está sobre la mesa la
ratificación del tratado entre mercosur
y la Unión Europea y va a asistir
precisamente a esta Cumbre josep borrell
el alto comisionado de la Unión Europea
para los asuntos exterior